hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to house i'm about to
kill my whole family
in this game oh take out that wink
that's horrible the implications are
terrifying um but also i need to kill my
whole family and the only way to do that
is to escape them after they're dead
when they come back to
uh to kill me in revenge for me killing
all of them
spit that was very unpleasant um i'm
wondering if i can make
that person
the neighbor lady appear sooner than
before i wonder if
do i need to kill you in comparison to
everybody else in this house i'm not 100
sure i need to kill
you let me see if i can get the old
neighbor lady to spawn
was it was it just night or was there
some other time
i don't remember didn't mean madre have
to wait
where's mother wait a minute what
where's my mother mother
mother mother where is
mother where is sister
wait how
how did you get past me i don't know
okay oh hi ma oh but you died on
accident
oh damn it okay well you stay there
oh god
well now this thing's coming after me oh
mom you never look better
i wonder if i can kill this thing what
if i put the the bear trap on the carpet
do you think it'll catch it
air trap get caught ah you go under it
ah you so smart oh
mom mom please no mom mom mom i don't
want to do this but i'm going to do it
damn i didn't have a bullet
oh hi sister
thanks mom thank you all right here we
go
hi kitty bye kitty hi buddy
bye buddy
mom you'll never get away oh god oh god
oh god
hey ma don't mind me i'm doing your work
it's fine don't think about it
hi sister uh bye sister
oh god no no no bye and then i just need
to uh
you know kill the neighbor
and then hopefully run away from uh it's
easter
hello thank you
okay you're there okay i'm going for it
okay well that's a problem oh god okay
climb up all the way
can i make this oh no no no no god damn
it oh
oh if i had just gone for it from the
get-go i would have been able to make
that i was so close
oh well you know what in the
perseverance of me trying to murder my
entire family
i'm not going to let anything get in my
way i'm not going to be dissuaded
this waged i'm not gonna be not do that
hang on
i might have just had a big brain moment
okay you're crying for a bit
maybe it'll give me just enough time to
get this spawn and get out of here
come on neighbor
neighbor no no no no no no you don't
okay thank you all right neighbor
[Music]
maybe neighbor neighbor baby neighbor
i also need to kill the rat i think
anyway i could just wait around wait
what's the hurry right the carpet goes
away after a certain time
neighbor oh god not you not you not you
oh [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
okay so
is the neighbor gonna show up when does
the neighbors show up
not 100 sure well i guess i'll just
i don't know
oh god that broke my thing uh i don't
need it maybe
maybe i don't need it at the moment wait
wait what the hell
what were you doing in there i just
killed you what
what ah okay i'm doing this all wrong
okay there was no problem with killing
everybody sooner it's just like the
shadow dude got me
so i'm just being a fool god you think
i'd be better at murdering my family
god that's what i get for trying to be
merciful i guess i better just be
cold-blooded right off the bat
i bet i i better just get all their
blood out of their body immediately
i i guess i just better fertilize
fertilizing
does it still count if i am the one that
caused this happen
that was me that was all me 100
me straight up me energy right there
i guess i can go ahead and kill the rat
i did get the bullet right
there we go okay you're dead and i'll
get another bullet here
so i got that now for the neighbor hey
neighbor
sorry neighbor whoo there oh stay away
from the kid
[ __ ] okay stay away from the kitty
okay it's fine
okay i had this crazy idea
if i put
oh
[Music]
i did it i did it i mean i kind of
does it count is my favorite little
monster feeling homicidal
i mean you know you know how it is yes
absolutely the blood must be spilt by
your own hand oh
come on i'll frickin shoot you
oh well that didn't go quite as i
planned it to
you mean i did everything right except
for the one step
of allowing my sister to have fate
befalling her i had everything perfect
god damn it just in case
it said buy my own hand so i'm going to
do it by my own hand
hello
[Music]
okay so that broke there i can shoot
this rat
bam the neighbors okay
oh that's a little weird oh well the
neighbor's not popping up
i don't know why why is you not there
what did i do wrong what have i done
wrong
why have i done wrong kitty killed me
nice easter okay so there's something
going on with the neighbor spawn
that's not working properly
so i'm just gonna try this again
[Music]
okay so how do you spawn
stay away from me kitty
because it might be that that summons
the neighbor there's the neighbor oh god
no
no no no come on not now you're going
no you're not you faded out okay
oh god the cat oh geez okay hey
neighbor just stick your neck out there
we go now you're dead
okay drop this on you oh okay you're
stuck
good oh no no no no no no not now not
now not now
okay is my favorite little monster
feeling homicidal
one last soul remains but where
so the neighbor wasn't part of it wait
who haven't i killed is it your soul
or do i just gotta wait until papa comes
home
and kill him unless
oh god the cat
oh geez
was that it oh
the house beckons to you your duty is
fulfilled
the house beckons to you what does that
mean what do you mean my duty is
fulfilled
what do you mean house beckons to me
what does that mean
what does that mean what do you mean
what do you mean the house beckons to me
what what
happy i'm home you've been a very good
girl oh
oh yeah that feels good
yeah that feels like a good ending blood
pools in doorways and seeps into the
carpet splatter covers the walls it
drips from your fingertips
great good your father grins madly and
embraces you
the darkness swallows you both leaving
nothing behind
great good i'm glad
that went well i'm very satisfied but i
have a funny feeling that's not the true
ending high
you must think you're so clever don't
you i bet you didn't even do it on your
own
you're wasting your time anyway you know
there's no way to stop it
it never ends great
good that's fantastic
so i'm guessing that the journal is
spelling out the endings that you can
get and i've only gotten two of them
and none of them have been the true
ending so let's see where this goes
bloodshed i thought it would be harder
than it was to think that the sighted
blood may be queasy before
now it's as natural as breathing so
there's definitely
more to this oh let me go check the
clock had blood on before so
the clock has more blood on it now
interesting so i've got two shotgun
shells and a bear trap i could
potentially
maybe i could potentially kill father
oh god that was close right
if i did it in this hallway like put
that there
maybe some while he's there
yeah maybe i could try this
daddy's home yes you are
i did get both shells didn't i oh
bang please tell me i got my shells
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
you fall to your knees exhausted father
is dead well that's a welcome change of
pace did it on my first try
ignoring all the other tries that tried
to kill father his head rolls over and
his glossy eyes shift at you just to
twitch once and no more
kind of weird the whole head popping off
and bouncing like that thing but i'm not
gonna question that the darkness
retreats but some more distant a fleshy
heartbeat can
oh ho a fleshy heartbeat continues
this is like a heart of the house
situation the house is alive
how cute you really think you can get
through with this
i don't even care anymore i was trying
to help you but go ahead
waste your time all you want i bet you
couldn't even do it without that snail
anyways
i mean i coulda i didn't you trying to
tell me something
trying to tell me that you're trying to
tell me something
trying to tell me let me just see what
the journal says and then i'm gonna
bring this one to a close because i
didn't expect to actually get any
progress there but
i did pretty quickly um and then maybe
one more episode where we get the grand
finale no but there's two more
right he's not human anymore i don't
know what he is but it's not him
is it strange that i felt relief after
not
particularly um considering what's up
with the clock
it's got to be something about a clock i
don't know what that's about
come on i want to talk to the neighbor i
know i chopped your head off and that
was really uncool but could really use
your uh help here
like a good neighbor i'm gonna guess
that i'm not supposed to do the
i'm not supposed to use the snail for
some reason
so i'm not gonna but at the same time
kind of [ __ ] wouldn't mind me having
a snail friend
oh god you there neighbor
neighbor tell me okay so there's gotta
be something about this beating heart
right
i'm willing to bet like it's uh the
house is alive kind of situation
not saying i've seen a lot of horror
situations before but that does seem
like something that might be
a bit of a thing here that slingshot
well where did you find that
oh you know i don't know
around there you are okay talk to me
please how are you feeling tonight your
sister pure of heart the house
ah you can guide her to safety i know i
can
uh all right so you're not helping me
much at all
so there's something about this house
like the whole idea of this
beating heart of the house i'm not sure
um let me talk to tabby i can't stop
seeing it your father the way his body
came apart the blood oh my the blood i
knew it had to be done but oh god
oh now debbie i need some time yeah i
know you do but there's got to be
something else
i wonder if i can shoot the the monster
that's in um
you know in this room i doubt it but oh
god oh god oh god y'all boom oops well i
shot the wrong way so i guess it didn't
really even matter
all right so
there's got to be something
that i'm going to figure out in the next
section an epithet episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
and remember if you don't listen to
distractible
which is available through the link in
the description below or by searching
for distractible on any of your podcast
sites
you will be left in a house that is
going to haunt you for the rest of your
days where you will
either have to save your family or
murder them but none of them are the
proper solution to get to the end
of the house so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below
and uh don't give me any spoilers i
don't wanna i'll figure this out on my
own in the next episode
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you